as the day cools down life slowly
returns to the bush in Southeast
Zimbabwe the African wild dog spent the
hottest part of the day sleeping in the
shade now in the late afternoon the pack
comes together ready to go out hunting
the perfect time for Jessica water Meyer
to check up on the pack she heads up a
conservation project for wild dogs in
the sava Valley Conservancy it's a
protected area that covers 3,000 square
kilometres she spent years working with
these animals and we've called them that
because as you can see they've got
beautiful and very distinct and colorful
markings and they also happen to be one
of the biggest packs in the Conservancy
so there are abadi live and adults now
started off the dating season or the
year 12
they had 14 puppies but we're down to
seven now and they're also obviously
just a very relaxed in the potato pack
as you can see so fantastic for us for
working with them and for monitoring and
research purposes wild dogs are among
the most endangered carnivores in Africa
with population numbers of around 7,000
at most the sava Valley Conservancy
provides a large area for them to roam
freely which is exactly what they need
to survive Impala antelopes are their
first choice of prey they are incredibly
social pack animals so just the way that
they interact with each other the way
they take care of each other the way
they take care of the puppies how all
pack members pull together to look after
each other
very different from other social
carnivores for example mine when wild
dogs either kill the adults relate the
puppies eat first they will look after
the injured they will take meat back to
the injured the survey Conservancy was
originally formed from an amalgamation
of large private ranches it finances
itself through tourism and controlled
sustainable hunting this means
endangered species are protected and the
area isn't sacrificed for farmland
outside the conservancy little of the
original bush remains the local
population has grown and more and more
land has gone over to farming leading to
increased contact between wildlife and
humans the conservationists now work
closely with local communities to
protect the animals Victor Chiba teaches
school students about how the wild
animals live he and his team visit the
schools three times a year many of the
children are fascinated the local
villagers often have a very different
take on how to deal with the wildlife in
their area
the Conservancy is the normally chased
them away if the Predators but if they
are before they know molecule them for
for meat so then the knowledge which we
are bringing all the scientific one is
no we have to coexist with even the
large carnivores and also the prey
species as well subbaiah teaches the
children about the food chain and
explains what happens when one species
dies out completely the idea is to help
the children see the importance of
conservation I think it's great to learn
about protecting the animals
and now I know that if poachers come I
need to report it to the police all my
teachers the wild dog project also
finances books and teaching materials
and even pays the tuition fees for some
of the students this school started
working with the conservationists in
2013 had master le an iguana says a lot
has changed since then you can actually
see that even if we see a snake if the
school is of loud they will tell you
that Oh Vic touch Maya doesn't like us
to kill these things they say please
leave this thing it's there to live
because it's called it is very important
for the ecosystem of those kids that is
actually positive this school we have
never had a kid you've been arrested for
poaching back in the Conservancy the
pack are hunting close to a kill but
this wildebeest is a little too big for
them still it provides a good sparring
partner for the younger dogs to hone
their hunting skills so after a little
excitement predators and potential prey
decide to go their separate ways but
African Wild Dogs are themselves exposed
to danger even inside the park as we
discover the next day Ranger king Kosovo
is out on patrol when a colleague
contacts him their confounded [ __ ] I
still feel well the dog dead you can
throw my snake
the Ranger immediately heads to the
scene where Jessica water Meyer is
waiting for EM it soon becomes clear the
situation is even worse than they
thought we got a report this morning
that there were two dogs that were
caught in wires they were still fighting
the wires so we rushed as soon as
possible and got here within 20 minutes
of the report but unfortunate by the
time we got you the dogs had already
strangled themselves and suffocated it's
a senseless killing
the dogs weren't even the target of the
poachers they set the wire trap to catch
antelopes the dogs tried to free
themselves by biting through the wire
but the copper was too tough
worse still it's the alpha male that's
been killed along with another adult dog
the best hunters in the pack the next
step will be for Scouts to work with
some of the local ranch guards and to
move through this area an ounce sweet
and make sure we can pick up as many of
these wires as possible ideally you pick
the wires up before this happens the
wire is almost invisible in the dense
bush and the area is vast but the
Rangers managed to find around 50 wire
traps dogs are unique to Africa we don't
find them anywhere else and as
conservationists working in Africa we
have a duty to protect them to make sure
they stay up for future generations and
they are completely genetically distinct
species once they're gone they're gone
the rest of the pack will stick together
until the juveniles are fully grown
fortunately the alpha female has
survived unscathed otherwise the pack
would have broken up but with her mate
now gone hopes of gaining a new litter
of puppies this year now looks slim